[Music]
I'm on set right now
it's 4 30 in the morning
um I just got up the first thing I do I
put the kettle on and then get in the
shower
and I'm a shower but you guys don't get
to see that for free no gotta show you
all the fifth
5am
I'm on my way to work I'm excited I
gotta have a lot of fun stuff there
today I'm gonna take you guys to my day
uh what it's like when I said about
there it's gonna be a good day hello
hello we're actually filming on location
and normally we film at the studio so
today we're filming at the house
everybody be asking is this a real house
girl new but when we work the outside
seams and the exterior seams that is a
real house and as far as free I'm
probably gonna listen to like a message
from a sermon or maybe even like a
podcast or just think like these are my
Still Moments this drive
damn not me being the first one in today
that wasn't even the first one called
let's go to set listen there's never a
day I come here and I'm not just
bewildered that I come to Universal for
a show called Bel Air what am I looking
forward to this season there's just so
many things first of all I'm looking
forward for y'all to see some of these
Fashions because some of these outfits
they just all need their own dance it's
like just exciting for us as it is for
everyone else to be like who are the
people coming on to guest star you know
[Music]
one thing that I do like to do once I
have gotten ready and they're not to my
scene yet I just kind of like turn off
all the lights in my trailer and I light
my little candle so tiny right there but
she's there
and I just meditate pray and just slow
down sometimes everything goes so fast I
just take in the slow moments and drink
tea we're in the hair trailer right now
before we do our big family scenes
that's why we have all the wigs
sitting here with the day of life man my
Barbara Taylor
hi my name is Ollie this Rob he give me
a good cut
[Music]
so now I am done with makeup the thing I
always say though is that when you have
the Michelangelo in front of you why
would you do that much you know what I
mean like it's just effortless me I'm
the Michael I'm the Michelangelo he's
a masterpiece you see how they
disrespect me I'm gonna go get changed
finally on the way to set on the way to
set me and Barry man this whole van just
for us because we are important we are
probably the most important character
easily by far Uncle Phil who right on
Viv where so it's called Carlton will
yeah Carlton's name no Carlton
it's doing really really great you know
Bill Bellamy's in the house you know
he's just been delivering just fire
oh Any Given Sunday
thank you
Oliver Stone great movie no no no way
what's happening y'all it's your boy
Bill Bellamy and the bell in season two
Bel Air I'm the most rich right now
you build me these are my two favorite
characters right here one cause he's the
leader of the family and then younger
right here coming up coming out here
trying to live a better way
next Generation we got it we gotta raise
them right we have a very big family so
happy to be here
oh
this is foreign
[Music]
so it's lunch and I'm eating we usually
hang out in my trailer although
sometimes we go to jabari's trailer I
hope we go to jabari's trailer today so
we just finished lunch and now me and
Jabari came to bother Cassie
because her trailer is so much nicer
than ours because she actually decorated
she puts carpet down she cares my son's
pictures are in here I have then I have
this picture on my side and he just sits
right here and he says
thank you
typically when they say cut New Deal we
kind of just like come to our holding
room and chill we see a curious got her
headphones on right now here over here
we have Funko and Cassandra
so yeah man you know it's just chill
like this is really the day in the life
this is kind of like every day we just
come back here to chill
here we are in Phil's office it's
currently like boarded not boarded up
but it's been you know because we're not
filming here tonight
she's actually really mean to me I want
you to know she actually bullies me a
lot um before I turn the camera on so
then we had to replace Carlton
and
okay working with Ali I just felt he was
a little
General actually uh rap about it Ali
Dolly what happened he wasn't so jolly
not like a Rancher that's what I'm
thinking before I fan
side note you know that she was born
before 1998 because she holds the camera
like this
um we're going to rehearsal right now
let me tell you something so it looks
like they're always people taking care
of us it's not true it's like they don't
want us to leave set if you think about
it it's like jail soon
this is such an adorable little picture
yeah it's wonderful because y'all really
all like my kids like I give y'all money
oh can I get some money can I get some
money these are my sisters
these are my sisters what and these are
my children
[Music]
we just ended a magnificent day yeah
at the end of special days we get
special food there you go got some
Popeyes for the end of it oh my God we
just finished another great day here in
Bel Air and what do I do at the end of
the day I come to my trailer and usually
you know what else happens you just
missed it but usually I have like a long
conversation with Adrian he's like my
next good neighbor and so me and Uncle
Phil usually talk about the day and the
truth is we always end it with just how
blessed we feel that we don't get to be
a family here and uh we just love
working on the show and the material
it's just like good heart medicine I'm
just getting done with set and I'm
immediately changing into a different
fit I'm gonna go meet my management and
have dinner and then I'm going to come
back and prepare my clothes for tomorrow
because we got to be up early and drive
far
I'm not picking out what I want to wear
in the morning end of the day we finally
wrap we got some dope shots today like
everyone pulled up but Bellamy was here
uh Anna Marie like it was it was a good
day Legend okay now I'm done putting my
clothes on let's go get this makeup off
and let's go
all right that was a good day so let's
go home in de-stress we're back in the
crib this has been a day in the life on
Bel Air
catch it later
[Music]
foreign